attention passengers please return to
your seats and fasteners are built you
know what that likely means turbulence
and if you've been getting on a plane
recently it feels like turbulence has
been getting a lot worse
so what does this mean for the future of
travel in a few decades time looks a lot
more turbulent with hundreds of percent
more severe clearer turbulence in those
skies and how are pilots reacting to
more and more rough air so we slow down
just a little bit to reach that
maneuvering air speed so that it doesn't
get bounced around as much
first we need to understand just exactly
what turbulence is turbulence is a
chaotic random motion that occurs in all
fluids it's around us all the time it's
in your bathtub it's in your cup of
coffee and of course it's in the
atmosphere
there are a bunch of different types of
turbulence but in particular we're going
to talk about cat no not that kind of
cat but clear air turbulence cat is the
particular type of turbulence that is
getting worse because of climate change
and since it involves clear air in the
jet streams it cannot be detected by
radar before a plane is in it today
right turbulence is generated by wind
shear in the jet stream anyone who's
ever climbed a tall building for example
the Eiffel Tower very calm at the bottom
but the higher up you go the windier it
gets and that increase in wind speed
with Heights is what's called wind shear
when the wind shear is too strong the
atmosphere simply can't contain that
when it breaks down into turbulence as a
result there are different levels of
turbulence you have light moderate
severe and extreme severe turbulence is
turbulence in which the up and downward
motions of the aircraft will experience
vertical accelerations that exceed one G
around 5000 aircraft annually encounter
severe turbulence in the U.S causing
hundreds of injuries to passengers and
flight attendants this severe
injury-causing ambulance is rare but of
course multiply that by all the planes
that are in the skies at any given
moment and one of them will encounter
that severe turbulence for Pilots
turbulence is about being in passenger
comfort and trying to figure out where
turbulence could potentially be and then
circumnavigating it so the force is on
an aircraft are lift weight thrust and
drag and air is a fluid it's keeping it
Airborne suspended at in flight at all
times and turbulence is like a minor
disturbance in the middle of it how is
climate change making turbulence worse
what satellites can see is the
three-dimensional shape and structure of
the jet stream and they've been
measuring that for at least four decades
there's an amplification of the warming
in the tropical parts of the planet and
that effect is increasing the north to
south temperature difference across the
jet stream and that's driving stronger
wind shear in the jet stream which is
generating more clear air turbulence so
that's the link from temperatures to
winds Shear to turbulence this is what
turbans look like 1979 and this is what
turbulence looked like in recent years
we see the same pattern except that the
hot spots are even hotter today there's
greater likelihood of encountering clear
red turbulence in those hot spots 50 or
60 percent more turbulence in some
regions and this is what turbulence
could look like if global warming
continues what we're looking at here is
supercomputer simulations of the
atmosphere now the simulation on the
left is our control simulation whereas
the simulation on the right is one in
which we've increased the carbon dioxide
to describe what a future real world
might look like with a lot more
turbulence in the skies that we fly
through what we find is that there's a
doubling or perhaps even a trembling of
the amount of severe clear air
turbulence in the atmosphere so the
future in a few decades time looks a lot
more turbulent with hundreds of percent
more severe clear air turbulence in
those skies and where will those hot
spots particularly be there's 55 percent
more severe turbulence over the North
Atlanta safe than there was in the 1970s
41 more over the U.S and similar figures
around the world that's the definitive
evidence really that clear red
turbulence has already started to get
stronger so what does this mean for air
travel in particular over areas like
North America and the North Atlantic
we're certainly projecting a doubling or
a trebling in the amount of turbulence
in a few decades time but that will just
mean that we go from 0.1 percent of the
atmosphere having severe turbulence in
it to 0.2 or 0.3 percent and that's
certainly not going to mean we're going
to have to shut down parts of airspace
and say there's too much turbulence I
don't think that's on the cards really
it's just a case of turbulence becoming
more frequent and Pilots needing to keep
even closer tabs than they already do on
where the turbulence is and trying to
avoid it as best as they can for Pilots
this means relying on programs like WSI
pilot brief and Sky path to plan our
flight routes you're looking at a God's
eye view of our route of flight the
various hazards along the way are those
big green circles and then the red boxes
if you look at the bottom half of the
screen that's a vertical profile you'll
see that toward the end if it stayed at
33 000 feet it would encounter that big
yellow and orange section of turbulence
and that's why in this case this
aircraft has chosen to climb all the way
up to 39 000 feet to try to avoid it
Pilots also use Sky path which
crowdsources turbulence data from other
flights caution turbulence detected the
yellow dots means they are encountering
light turbulence along the way and you
can see that if you hover over any
individual dot like that orange dot
there it'll show you you're going to
encounter moderate turbulence at flat
level four zero zero or forty thousand
feet with this information in mind
Pilots can decide to circumnavigate
turbulence for example by adjusting
altitude clear a turbulence caused by
jet streams tends to be due to a very
narrow band of air that's moving very
rapidly that narrow band of air may only
be two thousand three thousand feet
thick and if that's the case then you
can just climb or descend a couple
thousand feet and be out of it right
away so when we encounter clear air
turbulence the very first thing we'll do
of course is turn the seat belt sign on
make sure we call back to the flight
attendants and make sure they're either
seated if it's bad enough or that
they're checking the passengers are
seated if it's not bad enough we'll talk
to air traffic control right away we'll
figure out what the planes ahead of us
are seeing and if they're doing any
better at any other altitude so we can
climb or just send immediately and for
Pilots this also means going as fast as
safely possible to get through
turbulence most of the time when we're
flying through clear air turbulence
we're going to keep the auto flight
systems on oftentimes the auto throttles
though in severe turbulence are
recommended to be turned off and the
reason why is because those thrust
levers will be chasing around air speeds
pretty rapidly and it's not necessarily
good for the engines it's better just to
leave them in one steady place and hope
that the airspeed is not chasing itself
while Pilots are in turbulence they tend
to go out maneuvering air speed what
that is is the fastest speed that you
can fly have full deflection of your
control surfaces and not structurally
damage the aircraft so we slow down just
a little bit to reach that maneuvering
air speed so that it doesn't get bounced
around as much and that we can go
through at the quickest we can without
bouncing around the passengers too much
the airlines are constantly changing to
adapt to our Dynamic and changing air
travel environment so if climate
conditions make turbulence worse then we
will continue to evolve and make sure
that turbulence procedures are reflected
in that even if that means different
procedures to avoid it in the first
place
I specialize in turbulence I study it
every day I have done for 20 years but
even for me when I fly through
turbulence I feel that energy in my
stomach my heart racing it just plugs
into a very primitive part of our brains
that logic can't override and I tell
myself I understand you know this is why
I study I'm perfectly safe doesn't help
a tip I heard recently is to order a
drink and just put the drink in front of
you and watch how still the water
surface is in turbulence because the
emotions are a lot less severe than you
think
foreign